forward actually we're getting
armageddon
we're gonna get armageddon those two
black pawns are so scary and we saw duda
there he was kind of
nervously kind of moving the mouse back
and forth like half pre-moving half kind
of not committing to his moves but look
at these two black pawns
this one is so close to promotion
and it will cost white his knight at
some point
that white knight is getting kicked away
look at duda leaning back he knows he's
in trouble the pawns are rolling
the bar's going all over the shop
this is blitz chess through and through
anything possible and uh at the moment
white hanging on and yeah he's dropped a
bishop dropped his bishop
a blunder blue square
he just left his bishop on priests a
free piece for duda and this one is
gonna be decided magnus blundering again
duda takes it he holds his nerve a
handshake it's over young christophe
duda wins the match actually a smile on
magnus carlsen's face is blundered a
little bit today the world champion and
he loses the match but he does get 1